monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre de la Santé le président de la
République a dit clairement on a insisté
de reconstruire notre système de santé
pour l'adapter et satisfaire les
attentes des professionnels comme des
patients mais pour y parvenir une
réforme globale de l'organisation de ses
soins de leur mode de financement et des
synergies à mettre en œuvre est
nécessaire pour restituer une
attractivité perdue et profondé un
système innovant performant viable et
humains hélas les orientations proposées
posent davantage de questions que de
solutions efficaces et urgentes le
financement est absent totalement de ce
discours présidentiel sortir de la T2A
par exemple dès le prochain bel effet 16
pour lui substituer une rémunération
basée sur des objectifs de santé
publique négociées à l'échelle du
territoire fondé sur un critère
populationnel non défini ça laisse faire
plex comment imaginer que l'objectif
déficience puisse être atteint tout en
rendant la part de financement à
l'activité minoritaire c'est bel et bien
à notre avis sonner le glas de l'hôpital
quand on s'est mis le poste d'assistants
médicaux supplémentaires c'est pendant
trois ans l'assurance maladie qui
pérante quid de l'après et comment
l'assurance maladie paiera-t-elle quand
on sait que les 4000 assistants déjà
mises en place coûtent à celle-ci 160
millions d'euros les propositions
concernant la médecine de ville ne sont
pas à la hauteur et ne permettent pas
d'enrayer la crise de vocation ni la
propagation des désirs médicaux monsieur
le ministre comment entendez-vous
répondre avec précision et concrètement
aux attentes des soignants hospitaliers
et libéraux sans procéder à une
refondation complète des modes de
financement entre les différents
sénateurs que les différents financeurs
pardon que sont la sécurité sociale de
pas d'une part et les mutuelles d'autre
part